[Musique]
vous êtes malade depuis deux jours votre
employeur exige un billet du médecin
pour justifier votre absence au travail
vous vous retrouvez donc ici dans la
salle datant d'une clinique bon des
patients un patient qui ont un rhume
depuis 24 heures probablement pas besoin
de voir un médecin quand à moi c'est
tout ce qu'il faut prendre du repos bien
s'hydrater puis attendre que ça passe et
donc un patient qui était obligé de
consulter à cause de ça parce que son
employeur va exiger un certificat
médical dont va prendre la place d'un
patient qui est peut-être un problème un
peu plus grave médecin de famille depuis
20 ans et lycées ce ville a constaté que
des certificats médicaux sont demandés
de plus en plus souvent pour de courtes
absences ce genre de politique souvent
appliqué uniformément dans les grandes
entreprises et le secteur public est
dénoncée par la fédération des médecins
omnipraticiens le message qu'on lance
aux envoya c'est d'y aller avec
parcimonie sur ses exigences là sachant
très bien qu'on est en rareté une
ressource donc faut aussi garder l'accès
à l'eau services pour des besoins qui
sont vraiment justifiée selon le conseil
du patronat
la majorité des employeurs ne réclame
pas de billet du médecin pour des
raisons frivole mais la rareté de la
main d'oeuvre pourrait accentuer le
phénomène
c'est sûr que les employeurs lorsqu'ils
font face à de l'absentéisme sont plus
soucieux 1 sont plus préoccupés à savoir
comment assurer une bonne gestion de la
productivité da présence au travail un
jésuite de façon générale un employeur a
le droit de réclamer des certificats
médicaux pour trois raisons après une
absence de trois jours consécutifs
quand un employé s'absente de façon
abusive ou encore pour des motifs
douteux c'est l'obligation fondamentale
d'un employé d'offrir la prestation
travaille donc à partir du moment où il
met de l'avant sa situation médicale
mais d'une certaine façon il renonce en
partie à son droit à la vie privée
l'an dernier les canadiens ont manqué en
moyenne huit jours de travail parce
qu'ils étaient mal à ben pour les
employeurs l'absentéisme représentent
des dépenses supplémentaires de 15 à 20
milliards de dollars par année au pays
ici olivier bâche un réseau canada
montréal